hey guys at another hotel I don't know
the convention come Bravo but that's not
gonna stop the avatar V Long's this
episode this is the firebending masters
and this is the episode where Zuko is
joined up with Aang and he's gonna start
teaching him firebending but he finds
out his powers aren't so hot anymore no
pun intended and he can't seem to get
them going
so they both tried they both traveled to
this ancient city I guess where these
like the original people that put
firebending in to work and we're dragons
were inside me just like the creation of
firebending took place and sure enough
they find that there's people there and
they're still tribes and as we discover
it so it goes further and further there
are in fact Dragons which is pretty cool
and the only one that knew they were
around was the uncle and he kept it a
secret he kept it even a secret from his
nephew and everyone they knows because
the Dragons let him live and they
suspected that he was good enough to
keep his word now tell anybody and he
was so that's very cool oh so this
episode first of all it's sort of a fun
India Jones ish episode where there
there's booby traps
there's things trying to get them
there's these ancient artifacts there's
little riddles and treasures and so in
on that level it's really great fun uh
but on another level with the arrival of
the Dragons near the end which was not a
huge surprise for me but it was still
great to see and I love the way uh now
okay tennis I can talk about the way
they do the camera work on it but I like
the I like the reveal of what fire can
do and showing the possibility of fire
because so much of the show and their
perception has been that fire is a
destroyer as too dangerous and it
doesn't create and just that wonderful
scene where they the two dragons they
blow the fire together and it creates
all these various colors and you know
you see certain colors and fire before
you know you can see like a blue
or a red flame it's not always orange in
yellow but I mean they're seeing like
greens and purples and all these images
what a great creative idea and just
wonderful visual to see that so that
when you see them like seeing the secret
of firebending it's like you get it
visually I mean you don't know exactly
what they're seeing but you get that
same feeling as they're going through it
so I thought it was a very effective way
of showing it of course they do explain
it later as well so so you got that
going for it but what I really like and
this is why I appreciated mostly with
this episode about the show in general
what I realize is that now that Zuko is
teamed up with Aang it works so well and
what it made me realize is that I think
particularly with American entertainment
Americans are still very rebellious and
when you think about really what a young
you know nation we are it makes sense we
started from breaking away we started
from being rebellious and fighting back
and we won and we succeeded and we got
our independence and I think just
knowing that's our history and knowing
as long ago as I was it wasn't that long
ago we really look at like the grand
history of the world so Americans really
seem to love the underdog and they love
the rebel and we love the villains we
really enjoy villains uh and realizing
more and more we may enjoy them too much
and what I mean by that and I long
villains too you know I did the top
eleven villain song though what villains
at much um I adore villains and I love
really great villains and the show had
some great villains but what I realized
watching this now is that I think
because we got so villain happy we sort
of forgot that we forgot how to really
compliment the villain with a good hero
where it used to really be you
complement the hero with a good villain
and now you have the two together and
they were already working up how
parallel they were and how similar they
were and they complement each other so
well
I like seeing these two together and
that's two very well developed
characters put in a situation where you
want to see them together you want to
see how they interact you want to see
the relationship you want to see what
they say you want see what they learn
off each other and it's very rare that I
get a show where I can like both the
villain and the hero but you respect
them both sort of equally or you really
like seeing them together and here I
really do it's not well that character
is good but I love the villain or that
characters good but the hero is you know
to go and the villains to simp I mean
know they're both so good and in many
ways very parallel in many ways very
different and when they go on this
journey together and just seeing them
work off each other I really really
enjoyed it I loved seeing their
interaction and yeah again I think
there's just sort of this part of us
that so enjoys a really good bad guy
that we do serve forget to really like
the good guy um it's so often the bad
guys done - well you almost start
rooting for the villain um you know and
the heroes can be done well - but you
know who's ever met dress-up as I got
dressed up as the bad guy um so I like
the fact that this show does spend just
as much time developing just as unique
and good heroes as they do with their
villains it seems like everything is so
well balanced that way I know as a word
I use the lot describing a show but it
does feel just so well balanced um and
whilst getting - before before I sign
off you're just about the camera when
the Dragons come out um I said before
you know shaky-cam a lot of times it's
overused and silly but actually a lot a
lot of times can be very effective like
here where the Dragons come out and the
camera is slightly shaking out asking
myself why does this
work here and not in other moments
because there's lots of times I've seen
just people standing around and the
camera is moving you know sort of that
animation moving where you know the
camera can't really be moving its effect
they put it later and sometimes it can
be so distracting other times it can
really work and I felt really worked
here when those dragons came out you
felt the size and the weight of these
dragons I realized why it's because what
they're doing is that they're circling
around and so what it feels like it's
doing is that the wind and the weight
and the strength of them circling around
is shaking the camera so there it's
really justified it isn't just shaking
for no reason it makes you actually feel
the size of these things
and it's such a subtle little touch but
I imagine that scene if you took out the
little shaking of it I mean it'd still
be good but it wouldn't be nearly as
impressive just that little shaking when
the dragons are circling around worked
out really really well and that sound
does I do with the drive room although
those sounds going at me that that was
really great
but I think something about that shaking
again uh it just gave it that little
extra boom that it made it seem so much
larger um where so many animated shows
that particularly uh you know on
Nickelodeon and American cartoon series
couldn't cannot get that size and they
really understand how to capture them
they do such a good job of it
so yeah I really like this one a lot I
really love the interaction off these
two and it makes me realize more and
more just how well put together both of
them are both the hero and why me now
the other hero you know at the the
villain turns into the hero but that's
that makes even more interesting and
more complex I'd I loved it a really
really really good episode had a ton of
fun watching it and I'll just see you at
the next one figure